لكل الشعوب المحتلة عسكريًا
الحق في مقاومة احتلالها حتى ولو
عسكريًا. أنا لا
أؤيد الخيار العسكري في فلسطين، أفضل
الخيار الآخر، العصيان المدني
والعصيان، فقد أسقطت
الإمبراطورية البريطانية في الهند والإمبراطورية السوفيتية في
أوروبا الشرقية، وإسرائيل لديها
قوات عسكرية ساحقة.
التفوق ونحن نرى أمامنا ما يجلبه من
دمار ونسيان
لأهل غزة. أدين
بشكل قاطع
استهداف حماس لأهداف مدنية من أي عمر
أو جنس لأنها متهمة بمثل هذا
الاستهداف تكذب ادعاءات حماس
بالهوية الإسلامية هناك  أمر إسلامي
ضد قتل الأطفال الأبرياء
والنساء والشيوخ، الأمر أيضًا
ضد تدنيس أماكن
عبادة الحرب. كما أدين حماس باعتبارها تقدم
الأساس الأخلاقي الأعلى
لحكومة إسرائيلية يتم
تجنبها عالميًا حتى من قبل نصف
الجمهور الإسرائيلي  باعتباري فاشيا
وبغيضًا، فإنني أدين حماس لأنها أعطت هذه
الحكومة الفظيعة ذريعة
لتطهير غزة عرقيًا من مواطنيها
وقصفهم حتى
النسيان. أدين حماس لمواصلة
تقويض السلطة الفلسطينية
كما تفعل إسرائيل. أدين حماس
لتخريب محاولة السعودية  على
المملكة العربية السعودية التوصل إلى حل سلمي
لمحنة الشعب الفلسطيني، ولكنني
أدين بنفس القدر
القصف الإسرائيلي العشوائي
للمدنيين الفلسطينيين الأبرياء في غزة ومحاولة
دفعهم قسراً إلى القطاع.
وأدين القتل الإسرائيلي المستهدف
والاعتقال العشوائي للأطفال الفلسطينيين
والرجال والنساء.  في الضفة الغربية،
خطأان لا يصنعان
صوابًا، كنت أسمع
عبارة متكررة في وسائل الإعلام الأمريكية، هجوم غير مبرر،
ما هو المطلوب
من الاستفزاز أكثر من ما فعلته إسرائيل
بالشعب الفلسطيني على مدى ثلاثة أرباع
قرن من الزمان.  أحيلكم إلى المقال المنشور في
ميدل إيست مونيتور بتاريخ 17 فبراير
2014 تحت عنوان
قدامى المحاربين في الجيش الإسرائيلي يعترفون بدورهم في مذبحة
الفلسطينيين عام
1948، اقرأها وابكي كما فعلت هذا
العام فقط في الفترة من مايو إلى يوليو، حيث قُتل أكثر من 450
فلسطينيًا، من بينهم 67
يجب أن يتوقف إراقة الدماء للأطفال، أدين
إغلاق إسرائيل للأراضي الفلسطينية، أدين
المستعمرين الإسرائيليين
لاقتحامهم دور العبادة
في مسجد AKA في
القدس، أدين إسرائيل
لتدميرها منازل الفلسطينيين وبساتين الفاكهة الزيتون،
أدين إسرائيل
لاعتقالها النساء والأطفال الفلسطينيين
الرجال في معسكرات الاعتقال دون
اللجوء إلى الإجراءات القانونية الواجبة، أدين عمليات
القتل والاغتيالات التي تقوم بها إسرائيل ضد
الفلسطينيين، أدين إسرائيل لتحويل
أموال الأمعاء إلى
حماس، الجماعة الإرهابية التي حددتها
إسرائيل، أدين السياسيين الغربيين
لذرفهم الدموع عندما يقتل الإسرائيليون
على يد الفلسطينيين لكنهم يرفضون ذلك.  وحتى
التعبير عن الأسى عندما يقتل الإسرائيليون
الفلسطينيين لا يوجد أبطال في
هذه الصراعات سوى
الضحايا